this is a screenshot from an exercise on
Khan Academy it says the inter graphic
the interactive graph below contains the
graph of y is equal to log base 2 of X
as a dashed curve and you can see it
down there is that dash curve with the
points 1 comma 0 and 2 comma 1
highlighted it just the movable graph to
draw y is equal to 4 times log base 2 of
x plus 6 minus 7 and so if you happen to
have this exercise in front of you I
encourage you to do that or if you're
just thinking about it in your head
think about how you would approach this
and I'll give you a hint
to go from our original y is equal to
log base 2 of X to all of this it's
really going to be a series of
transformations and on this tool right
over here what we can do is we can move
this vertical asymptote around so that's
one thing we can move and then we can
also move two of these points so where
we're starting is right we are starting
right over there and so let's see and
that was just the graph of y is equal to
log base two of X so let's just do these
transformations one at a time so the
first thing I am going to do instead of
just doing log base two of X let's do
log base 2 of X plus 6 so if you replace
your X with an X plus 6 what is it going
to do well it's going to shift
everything six to the left and if that
doesn't make intuitive sense to you I
encourage you to watch some of the
introductory videos on shifting
transformations so everything is going
to shift 6 to the left so this vertical
asymptote is going to shift 6 to the
left it's going to go B instead of being
it at x equals 0 it's going to go all
the way to x equals negative 6 this
point right over here which was at 1
comma 0 it's going to go 6 to the left 1
2 3 4 5 6 and this point which was at 2
comma 1 it's going to go 6 to the left 1
2 3 4 5 & 6 so so far what we have
graphed is log base 2 of X plus 6 so the
next thing we might want to do is what
is 4 times
log base 2 of X plus 6 and why you think
about it is whatever Y value we were
getting before we're now going to get 4
times that so when X is equal to
negative 5 we're getting a y-value of 0
but 4 times you are still 0 so that
point will stay the same but when X is
equal to negative 4 we're getting a
y-value of 1 but now that's going to be
4 times higher because we're putting
that 4 out front so instead of being at
4
it's instead of being at 1 it's going to
be at 4 so this right over here is the
graph of y is equal to log base 2 of x
plus 6 and then the last thing we have
to consider is well we're going to take
all that and then we're going to
subtract 7 to get to our target graph so
whatever points we are here we are now
going to subtract 7 so this is at y
equals 0 but now we're going to subtract
7 so we're going to go down 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 I went off the screen a little bit but
let me see if I can scroll down a little
bit so that you can see that see almost
there you go
now you can see I move this down from 0
to negative 7 and then this one I have
to move down 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 & 7 and we're
done there you have it that is the graph
of y is equal to 4 times log base 2 of X
plus 6 minus 7 and we are done